vous dites souvent que les super héros
sont des justiciers mais l'autre jour je
regardais batman et je vais demander est
ce qui rend la justice
ou est ce qui rend pas plus tôt sa
justice et surtout batman avec sa
situation de milliardaires privilégiée
dans une fille très pauvres s qui
n'alimentent pas une injustice qu'il
tente de combattre la notion de justice
elle est assez complexe et varié un
plateau ont été l'un des premiers à dire
que c'est une notion qui touche non
seulement à la cité dans notre cas à
gotham mais c'est aussi une notion qui
est en nous et donc en batman car c'est
ce qui va garder chaque chose à sa place
tout en maintenant une harmonie de
l'ensemble
donc ça n'a pas que le sens habituel
pour platon mais c'est un tout autre
sens interne qui est cet arbitrage entre
la raison et les passions par exemple et
du coup possiblement entre ce que veut
batman est ce que vous soyez féconds et
comme un examen pour ces chefs c'est
grâce à elle que les hommes vivent
ensemble naturellement et régis leurs
comportements personnels collectif et
maintient ainsi chaque chose à sa place
en gros la justice et aussi une vertu et
c'est aussi elle qui va pousser de
batman à ne jamais tuer car cela le
conduirait à de l'injustice et pas
forcément injuste pour la cité mais
injuste dans le sens où il est serait
alors une partie de lui prend le dessus
sur une autre ainsi une scène dans un
des batman de double oui nique ou batman
nous dit qu'il aimerait tuer le joker
mais que s'il le faisait il
s'autoriserait aller à un point duquel
il ne reviendrait pas plus parce que
batman c'est une personnalité plutôt
complexe ça et rodez dc comics créé par
bob kane en 1939 à l'histoire c'est que
tu as un fils de milliardaire bruce
wayne qui devient orphelin très vite
dans la version originelle le petit
brousse et ses parents sortent tard du
cinéma un bandit les agressent et tue
son père au pistolet et sa mère fait un
arrêt cardiaque dans la foulée j'espère
vraiment que le film valait le coup
c'est suite à cet événement que batman
va mettre des cédants de traquer les
méchants avec des super gadgets et graff
et de la maxe itunes donc c'est un
événement particulièrement triste qui a
construit batman et son aventure
commence par une grande injustice dont
il est victime
pourquoi moi pourquoi est ce que ma
famille était au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
mais cette injustice il ne fait pas
qu'en super les aspects négatifs ils
vivent injustice aussi dans des côtés
plus qu'ils font
je suis comme je vous le disais c'est un
milliardaire et c'est son seul super
pouvoirs ainsi ce n'est qu'il a une
mémoire eidétique ce qui lui donne en
gros une de mémoire
photographique
après jean pas dans le détail de la
force de la maîtrise des arts etc voilà
j'ai pas considérer ça comme un super
pouvoir ni sa mémoire eidétique mais en
gros il ya une vraie inégalité
entre la situation est aisé de bruce
wayne et celle précaire de la ville de
gotham alors attention là ça a du sens
de parler des inégalités surtout parce
qu'ils en hérite directement un
s'arrêter un peu plus complexe s'il
avait gagné cet argent par son travail
dans tous les cas vu qu'il est au coeur
de cette bulle de richesse dans une
ville où règnent la misère et la
violence
batman c'est mieux ça me saoule
injustice et c'est ce que peuvent
ressentir certaines populations de
gotham qui sont pros malfrats et que
personne ne protège puisque il en a été
lui-même victime
c'est ici que les travaux d'un autre
philosophe sont intéressants à étudier
john rawls alors c'est un philosophe
américain contemporain né en 1921 est
mort en 2002 et il a fait de la justice
son objet de travail principale la
situation de richesse dans laquelle se
trouve athmane elle en train d
inégalités sociales avec le reste de la
ville de gotham et les inégalités
sociales pour john rawls elles doivent
suivre plusieurs règles il faut que ces
inégalités soit pour le plus grand
profit des plus désavantagés et que ces
inégalités soient attachés à des
positions et des fonctions ouverte à
tous
en gros les égalités ne sont pas
réservées à un type de personne et
peuvent toucher tout le monde
hors ligne et et social ça peut être une
grande forme d'injustice qui est proche
de celle que combat batman puisqu'en
fait batman il combat lui ni qualité
sécuritaires qui est étroitement liée à
l'aide sociale
en tout cas à gotham est ce que des
rôles c'est qu'il peut y avoir justice
tout en ayant une inégalité de statut
économiques ou sociaux et seuls les
inégalités qui ne sont pas au plus grand
profit des désavantages et sont
considérés comme vraiment injuste et
là-dessus bruce wayne est d'accord et
grauls dans le sens où lui-même fait
partie d'une certaine inégalité de
statut je rappelle que le mec est
milliardaire mais il ne va pas
considérer cette inégalité comme de
l'injustice sinon il aurait dilapidé sa
fortune et le comique se sera arrêtée au
bout de dix numéros parce qu'il aurait
porté à pôle emploi
pourquoi est ce qu'ils considèrent pas
son inégalité comme de l'injustice parce
qu'il fait profiter son inégalité au
plus grand nombre avec les donations
wayne puisque wayne enterprises possède
une fondation la fondation wayne a trait
à laquelle il va développer entre autres
la rougeur scientifique et l'aide
sociale des moyens de lutter contre la
criminalité et restaurer l'ordre dans la
société de gotham mais ce qui est super
intéressant c'est que cette activité de
bruce wayne et rentre en parfaite
complémentarité excellent de batman la
nuit batman il met à profit ses armes
technologiques hors de prix ces
capacités quasi surhumaines
d'investigation et de combat on punir le
crime et faire régner la paix et le jour
botwin ils complètent cette action en
mettant à profit l'argent de wayne
enterprises et le savoir de ses membres
pour continuer le travail de batman on
peut dire que l'injustice que connaît
batman elle est utilisée pour gommer les
inégalités sociales de gotham ces
inégalités sont pour le plus grand
profit des désavantages et on est
parfaitement dans ce qu'explique rôle on
voit la complexité autour de l'injustice
que va illustrer batman ils essaient de
résoudre l'injustice qui baigne dans
gotham tout en conservant son égalité
par rapport aux autres dans la creuse en
même vu que sa boîte cherche à faire du
profit mais dans le but d'en faire
bénéficier les plus démunis et on
retombe également sur la notion de
justice de platon puisque les
comportements de batman sont régis par
sa vertu personnel et ont pour visée de
maintenir l'ordre dans la société
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour batman
évidemment tout ça c'est des
interprétations que vous en aurez
sûrement de différentes mais j'espère
que ça à éveiller votre curiosité sur
quelques points n'hésitez pas à mettre
vos interprétations à vous dans les
commentaires et à lâcher un pouce tout
ça aide au référencement de la vidéo
cette vidéo c'est la première vidéo 2010
est donc j'en profite pour vous
souhaiter une très bonne année bonheur
santé amour et réussite dans tout ce que
vous entreprenez et j'espère qu'on
passera une année 2010 cet ensemble
encore mieux que celle de 2016
love peace